yeah words yeah as it should
bonus stream the stream that was
supposed to happen the first time I
suppose
overwatch happens brigetta brigetta
alright Vegeta yeah Bridget yeah
whatever I'm so sick of this yeah so
anyways we're bringing to you hopefully
the last metal hopefully last Metal Gear
thing middle gear survive okay yeah we
played the first you know we played
earlier on in your save I forgot how
many hours in that was but it was like
eight or ten a day eight to ten hours
now you've beaten the game yeah yeah and
you've finally unlocked subclasses which
is a big thing too and there's like more
to the endgame then like the
single-player so obviously it kind of
like it opens up into a look at like a
free-for-all survival thing if you take
the key the the main ending cuz they're
multiple endings to this game both of
which might be like a weird backhanded
Canon type of deal but I'm not gonna
talk about that how about you talking
about the fact that it would potentially
cost you $10 more to get that old oh
yeah ending so I can't go back to get
the alternate ending after I've gone
this route and the only way I can do it
is by either deleting my character or
paying $10 to go back and redo it all
feels bad man and there was like this
little glimmer of hope I remember when
we were streaming the first time that
like maybe you get an extra character
when you beat the game and that didn't
happen no also for those curious we do
have a review in product I think the
review is actually up I think we're
getting the review the review is up the
video yeah the video review is on its
way it's coming in hot
probably in the next couple hours or so
someone who's saying well if I recall
correctly was it a five I think it's a
five yeah I think it's a five so
GameSpot gave it five out of ten
but somehow been djenka here outside of
me forcing him probably to get the
cinematic so we don't play this game
that ending cinematic up
I was reading through the comments today
and all of us just like God bless the
poor person had to play through this
entire game and I'm like that was me
except for the most part you probably
would have beat it regardless right
maybe not as soon as you did but like
you probably you were enjoying it enough
to kind of you know yeah I surprisingly
too much of a dumb Metal Gear fan to
just say no and of course I kept playing
it but yeah cool
so are you forcing the one subclass or
is it more that you can pick from the
like they're like so do we want to talk
about that yet or is gonna head over
there after I say sweet potatoes because
it definitely needs AI what's up with
this sweet the sweet Jam oh so I put
quiet steam in because I need to be
constantly reminded of how sad it is
that this game exists you can do that
yeah so you gonna actually unlock
Castlevania music so I can probably cue
that up so if you you look it like these
playlists you can build out see here at
a playlist you can go to that one yeah
so I got like vampire killer wicked
child we've got some police nots in here
like whatever you're feeling like okay
you just find those in the world I'm
guessing yeah awesome lunar Nights 2 but
yeah so like I leave I leave quiet steam
up just to make sure everyone feels like
the appropriate amount of sad spare I'm
like you I have no name says how is this
game game getting so much publicity it's
getting way more attention than it
deserves I think part of it is I want
curiosity I think from my perspective
and even like you had brought up this
idea before I even thought about it
earlier in this week was like trying to
help inform the masses out there to help
them understand like hey this is what
the game looks like after single-player
do you want to get to this point do you
even want to play the single place it's
very much like a survival game where you
get more out of it the more you put in
so it it gets better the further on you
get it's just it's really unfortunate
that it had to be tied to to the Metal
Gear name I guess yeah but that was the
only way yeah you know they're gonna
print that money if they are printing
any money oh here we go yeah so know
once you you get you finish the story
then you have to finish a quest where
you learn to like I guess
subclasses but it'll unlock the the four
classes for you assault Jaeger medic and
scout I've go and Scout right now
because it lets you like repair things
okay and so you have access to all of
those subclasses right it's not like
you're you have to necessarily get
locked into one it's just how you two
prefer to level them up you can switch
them out I think it's it's on a
different screen where you do it but you
can actually switch which one is your
active one okay we'll just kind of
attach it to the board of your your
actual you can just say oh here let me
get rid of this you can see everything
yeah
so those is that coupon energy is that
what that was to level it up yet still
the still the same currency to level up
and they give you a whole new set of
skills so like I picked up this thing
where anytime I collect materials I get
all of them at once now if I stab
something I don't have to lean over and
pull it off I just get it when I stab
the person in the back see note zero 84
what's the endgame like once you finish
the single-player campaign is it only
co-op so it's it opens up and I actually
kind of expected it's just be like a
survival game like whatever you just go
and like gather stuff and keep going
until you can but they keep throwing
things like there are more survivors to
get okay and then this thing that
happened that we're gonna go and check
out nice I don't know what it is because
I started it up and I'm like I should
probably save this for the stream but
they keep throwing enemy types at you
and I hadn't seen this so there's new
enemies that are past the single-player
so that's pretty interesting you know
something you know yeah I haven't fought
this thing yet I guarantee it's gonna be
a wild ride but ready for it
kudos no it's like cool in this space
then DOS
saying this game is really great it's
not as bad as everyone is making it out
to be
yeah it's not true Metal Gear but the
gameplay and salvage missions are really
a ton of fun I think it's a there is
definitely like that camp of people that
found a way to persevere if that's the
right word I don't know like they they
kind of
saw through some of the flaws and enjoy
but you know like there's a different
gamers out there that enjoy different
things so this definitely fills a niche
for some people it's a game that it
obviously is not a Metal Gear game but
there's enough here to actually kind of
kind of do a thing you can't mess up the
Fox engine to the point where it's
unplayable it'll always be a playable
game and whatever you put around it is I
guess it's Norman Reedus what's that oh
god it's like a weird floppy dinosaur
thing this is starting to turn into
monster I don't know yeah that's exactly
where I was excited to do all the boys
stuff this morning cuz it went live and
I'm like apparently the boss were headed
for we'll take 15 minutes but he isn't
too bad okay pretty big uh he's a big
boy yeah okay this is I'm ready to die
sure I think so one more deadly venomous
creatures is this your first boss
creature it must be if you just got the
Toro tutorial rather yeah well that's 34
guys are beefy I can't use my my old
equipment on it I gotta swap it out this
is what do you have now what is that
it's a really cold sword I guess really
cold it's it's really cool it damn it
that eases things I that's fine
it was no let I'll let it slide this
time are you level 44 then how would I
say no I'm just like regular 40 oh so
they're finally actually giving you a
higher level stuff wow that shotgun does
work the shotguns very nice finally got
some purples I like it I'm like Oh get
out of here get out of here
oh hello probably should have paid more
attention to that yeah yeah it's fine
those not what we did the big dog you
know oh no I'm also in a really bad
place because I didn't get a chance to
like appropriately do the
the last mission some kind of low on
supplies anyway but that's much better
what are we fine we'll be right there
though just say no oh you just work Oh
big mouth my name is big mouth okay uh
is he shooting what is going on I don't
like any of this I'm gonna leave our pip
out for now because I feel like you know
we want to experience this boss what is
happen big mouth ooh yes yes do that
he'll spray hello
no damage though you no harm no foul
he's got one giant arm oh that's his
machine gun machine gun arm can't this
why Chris little crit though Ben just
gotta hit him in his big mouth you know
what's funny that thing kind of looks a
little bit like the monster I was
fighting the sword art online really
kind of because his weak spot was like
his forehead kind of thing you know
oh hi it's funny how he has no left arm
but his his strong arms a machine gun
you know he has kidding haha you think
that you can grenade me I kind of wish
that I could like monster hunter and
like paralyze it trap it or something
yeah flashbang it okay I want to try
something really quick Oh what is that
next level stretch for a little break
and four breaks goodnight hacks in there
I did that one by accident while lord I
don't know what limit that was
breakdance breakdance grenade technology
yikes
well this is gonna be this dream I think
unless I'm good I feel good about this
he's lost like ten percent you don't
know if he's one of those like bosses in
those games where after a while you know
he's gone
weekend he drops like a good 15% I'm
gonna go with probably not and you're
probably gonna be slowly whittling him
away yeah hi
kudos will tell us if technically he
said for now the stomach an header crit
area is this Oprah now for now to do
that
hey okay alright unless I'm crazy it
appears as if he switched hands he's now
got a sword arm on his left arm and he
doesn't have a gun on his right arm
yeah am I crazy for that think of that
or looks looks like a sword for sure I
don't like all of what Evers asked if
he's pooping on you so what the hell
happened to his right arm is what I am
wondering oh there's the reach oh did he
break his arm off yeah oh he's weak time
to go ham look look at his arm it's like
oh hi have a grenade would you like
taste to on there I'm gonna oh he does
he grows arm back as like something else
damn well find out uh not yet at least
we can see the dent in him now oh yeah
yeah just clip your toes gotta watch
your toes as the FGCs would say this is
think there are people who will plot
this well the funny thing about that
mitch is if you want to plot it platinum
it rather that would technically mean
you would have to beat it twice right
then which means we'd actually spending
$50 eventually if you do the alternate
ending I think it actually just sends
you back to the menu and you get to pick
up and do the mission normally so it's a
missed opportunity for you if you did it
the real ending first then you're kind
of bone yeah that seems kind of crappy
ah why do I have this gun it's just a
like a dumb slingshot yeah you know to
tickle him oh he's got that he's he's
got the machine gun arm back how he does
with fire come on closer don't that's
fine he's over there
yeah he's got a he's like ed-209 right
now it's Todd chillin hanging out here
have a what was that little Molly I
guess have a very low level Molotov
stack them do it keep burning them I'm
actually shocked that the like the
platforms don't break though yeah I kind
of do you know what I mean I expect big
mouths here to just to really just
annihilate every day exactly alright
don't mind us you know what he's pooping
out of his mouth yep
yeah a lot of a lot of circles they're
red circles means bad more preparation
probably would have been good
yeah well ridin down we're fine worst
case it will run away I've got so what
happened can you can you crap on the fly
here no yeah you gotta do it all in at a
bench well we might have some issues
here that Ben yeah your Ambo nishan I'm
also running out of oxygen I probably
should have brought a mobile tank you
brought a lot of stuff I think yeah I
thought it was just gonna be like oh
it's like a new enemy type you know
whatever and realize it was a boss who
he's like artillery bones and so I did
500 that time that seems pretty good
just think we busted open is like are
you though more damage you don't
question more damage y'all are scum for
support in this game well for why you
should you should we're helping you if
anything we're helping people see that
it's a thing they don't want to buy
potentially or or in some sick way they
might want to buy it maybe yeah sword
arm sword arm online oh okay it gets
green
I feel like bad news is coming
we see a little wind effect you go yeah
you are I'm like what do you got well
you got everything
Oh 46 more arrows these are the the
starter arrows is it time to run men oh
he's kind of limping though he's he's
not he's not he's he's fine he's gonna
give me he's actually going out me
bigmouth hungry man my dude I'll see you
later all right
turns out you know just we're calling
we're gonna call it a reprieve we're
just gonna take a little break
let him do his thing we'll come back on
the other side I have to do this anyway
yeah cube don't find some some real
scary boss creatures of the Internet are
boss creatures only Osama only I was
being paid by Konami to stream this for
you if only one day then we would be
rich yeah oh oh you're lucky I didn't go
through the fence there man you know
there's a there's there's a point out
here I can tell because of the light I'm
Jana run the opposite direction do it no
right I know that's what I'm saying we
did all that work yeah we did ten
minutes of work all for naught yeah but
yeah I mean video review is on its way
probably in a couple hours and then the
review is actually out again so I gave
it a five out of ten
so yeah you can check that out two more
in the UK review de forests if you're
interested if you're not I suppose
you're here for a reason either to see
where it goes yeah either to tell us
that you're here to dislike cuz no
Kojima or why are you playing this game
okay it's a fair question you need to
know yeah well I was actually I was
actually shocked that there was actually
that much more after single-player I
guess yeah right I kind of expected it
to
stop and drop off it could I still think
they should have probably mmm I feel
like the subclass thing should have just
been in at a certain level or something
as you're going through single-player
mm-hmm I don't know maybe it's the thing
you're supposed to look forward to after
yeah I don't know anyway all right we're
gonna what are you gonna do here let's
tack this off because that's the only
thing I can do okay do you feel like
we're in a position to kill that thing
potentially or not so much uh if I spent
time gathering some resources to craft
some stuff maybe okay so what do you
what what else would you like to do
right now the alternative to actually
just get resources while we're doing
stuff is I could just jump into the the
co-op because that is the other big
thing let's do it you kind of do yeah so
what's different what changed when you
beat it was there anything that changed
coop wise after you beat the game just
more places to go okay yeah we can that
really quick it's nice also because my
hunger and thirst don't drop while I'm
in there yeah that's good no problem joy
uh Darren joy aid it's Erin that's a
tough one to say no problem anytime yeah
that's that's the other thing too I
agree with Chris like it's not a bad
game overall it just sucks and it's a
Metal Gear game like that that's the
only way I can describe it yeah but I
feel like I mean deep would you have
bought a survival game not with the
Metal Gear
I'm not a big survival tactic to you but
yeah yeah that's a very fair point like
I just don't know if that would have
been enough you know yeah c-can I I'm
not crafting I need to grab my stuff out
first that I already have made yes
Carlos it is $10 for a safe lock yep
which it's little weird that they would
do that said all these other things
about repetitive gameplay and micro
defections those are also true the best
was when we built that shop that that
was just microtransactions yeah well
luckily you got Alpha Team as part of
that deal there but
yeah how has that been the whole like
sending out together I've only done it a
couple of times and you got to give up a
lot of your resources to send them out
and felt like it wasn't the best thing
but are there vehicles in this game to
use oh yeah the walkers and jeeps those
are definitely there I'm running
anything else but I'm just gonna grab
all these and I forgot that the music
that you chose plays in the lobby still
so I'm still real sad listen in the club
is the story sort of make sense are not
really at all I it's coherent enough but
it's kind of a joke yet their whole
rationalization is literally just
nanomachines like they tried to carry
that over from from the other Metal Gear
games on top of everything else I mean
kudos brings up a point that says you
don't need another save slot at all but
why so if that is the case then why even
make it $10 Yeah right like at that
point like if that is if that is
legitimate you know that because kudos
likes the game obviously and I'm not
trying to argue with them it's just that
if you don't actually need another save
why make people pay $10 it seems
ridiculous I would like to have like at
least two slots yeah I mean the only way
is if you missed the the trophy Yeah
right if you screwed that sequence up so
there's part of me that wants the trophy
but I think I can put that behind me and
not worry about it too much
BAM I also kind of feel bad because that
ending was really cool I'm the only way
I could watch it was by going on YouTube
and watching someone else have it yeah
exactly money it's it's all money I know
but but now oh of course they have the
how do you have that thing how do you
get that he's probably find it somewhere
dang that's right that's a cool little
cool little emblem I'm all about the
emblems I'm feeling that one game Bill
Monroe real strong I came from destiny
man let me let me have something that's
all
ya know I'm I'm in that's probably one
that was inside of one of the boxes all
right oh let's see oh you got a bunch of
greens coach Joker can't believe that
that little revolver that you had what a
purple version which we're gonna get it
carried by these two I'm okay what do
you mean those two one guys only 37 oh
here we go
get out of here freak game this freak
dance grenade as soon as I learned that
you could kick grenades away that's
that's little field goal I'm a I'm a
talk ghost Joker thing today you might
be like Oh apparently you get a trophy
for feeding an exploding drum to
bigmouth
oh so off the craft one of those bring
it with me next time I like it so I must
mean you probably fight them more than
once to you no problem mhm said thanks
for playing this so others don't have to
yeah I think it's a good viewing
experience yeah I think John Luke was
like hey yeah I wasn't gonna play the
game so I just kind of like watch the
cutscenes and the endings and yep thanks
I was like how a lot of people like it's
the first time we've ever done like an
ending cutscene video where people in
the comments were like no I don't think
this really counts for spoilers I think
this is more like a public service than
like like a spoiler warning kind of
thing the danam says you can kick her
name's now Wow Raiden would be a ride
and would be so impressed he would it's
true yeah you can kick grenades for some
reason the I'm gonna clip that one out
from earlier if no one else did because
I'm it actually hit him when I did it
look real good Chris there's no doubt in
my mind I'm pretty sure there's no doubt
in Ben's mind that this is a cash grab
oh no definitely 100% 100% there's
literally no reason to have Metal Gear
name on it other than an excuse to reuse
the assets from you Samus Ohio says Jess
I curiosity how deep is character
customization if you played well you're
on line three it's just that but in here
there you go Oh health boost I actually
kind of liked this stage this is a good
one
nice glad we got it then yeah right
see going to to put my thing up here
because I can't trust people to enable
the with that the speed up thing oh I'm
going to some fences
we gotta my hogs yeah I like everything
I have to go actually because the
materials you use our materials you pick
up in the world right yeah yeah yeah you
didn't do the the pre farming part of
this Oh someone skipped it well oh this
is fine
who needs materials yeah not me forget
about it I'll just use my bow the whole
time
yeah even kudos who enjoyed the game
said yeah I definitely enjoy the game
way it is definitely for monies yeah
it's it's very obvious that it is this
person just gonna handle everything I
wanted like here let me shoot know what
I'm just gonna let them handle this and
I'm gonna go collect stuff cuz I'm never
inevitably we're gonna have to like
actually crap some things and we do have
people who are using the booster so
that's good alright oh that guy is just
that guy is just Bartman he's off he's
off grabbing stuff for us if some boxes
get some paper some screws fantastic
is there any references to the older
games like a little bit sometimes like
characters will say lines that are
almost like quotes for other other
characters like at one point the
computer AI like quotes the sorrow oh
nice you got the I don't know if you did
it but that hot invisible wall alright
looking good so far
yeah I don't think they've they've got
well no they did get up to it well
because I feel like a couple of year off
doing a side stuff yeah and that guy was
was killing it with this is what we need
yeah there's those fire things though
either the arrows or Molotov or any
other yeah
I'm still holding I hope that one day
we're gonna see a metal gear you know
maybe today I'll be the day if we went
digging enough alright I think after
this I'm gonna head back in all that
hello this is this is very much TNT
explosives metal yeah a bundle of Steel
it's really weird that it's not doing my
group wait a minute do I have to assign
it you're asking the wrong guy I know
wow there's so much stuff to pick up
blue batteries awesome batteries Oh why
your wormhole digger took some damn look
damage there yes I thought that the one
guy would be able to do it but I guess
not
you're over here grab the boxes so I
don't think you can expect much they're
just saying we should be good now on
though I got you got materials we can
craft some stuff I'm gonna boost the
extractor again oh you never know mhm
they could still remaster those things
yeah I feel like they probably will cuz
it's the safest way to to get money from
Metal Gear fans it's all my HD remakes
of oh yeah one two and three yeah did we
did we talk about the secret message
about potentially bad-mouthing the game
not really I don't know
did you look too much into that I didn't
that much I mean it obviously says kjp
forever like it's not even like a
question kind of I mean it if someone
did it it's kind of cool it's clever
probably not a smart thing to to
bad-mouth the people who like work over
you but yeah this is his one last his or
her one last hurrah I rego this guy's on
it
Oh what is all of that it's a bunch of
like spinning blade but setup not or
they do anything I don't know what that
is I don't know it's there for show yes
so should probably go back up to it
sounds like someone may have got yeah
Christopher Graham
Granger he knows that you don't get to
keep the supplies you gather in online
well they're just for building yeah also
you get special we get the rewards at
the end for yeah
everybody's gonna die let's do it
hmm the damage is much better than
earlier yeah
level starts to kind of do weird things
when you get into like the 40s come here
you get stabbed you okay
got his leg fell off yeah don't mean he
doesn't need that no he really doesn't
get out of here
one of them got up again
I'm just gonna stay up here yeah I mean
whoa there's a lot yeah they're a lot
coming a little too firm horn
so I'm coming in with the shot Gotti and
here you are trying to aim and he's just
like oh I got forget about it smokes
tobacco I got he's doing it yeah oh here
have some sandbags
and we gotta watch the other side too I
should probably just block it off what
the other time yeah cuz it they came up
through that way as well well barbed
wire fence it's nice because it does
damage to him so I can tell when they're
there because the numbers pop up whoa I
hear like some guy have like a walker or
a gallon gun oh he's getting shot okay a
cool turret
I think someone's just spending our
energy for technical support yeah I was
gonna wait till we get the Walker gears
but that's just me there it is griefing
the guy oh yeah cuz the the heavy shots
actually kind of like some bagger
[Music]
I think it's pretty much in the bag
we're gonna get astragalus which is nice
I think this is only a normal difficulty
one though how high does it uh
difficulty wise ago
I've seen it it's up too hard I believe
okay but from what I hear hard was like
super hard but they had to like patch it
or something and they had to change the
way that rewards got distributed and
that was like how you said you could
pretend to get orange gear is that what
yeah I think the S rank tier for hard it
gives you orange gear or has a chance to
give you orange gear basically what we
perceive as the highest level yes stuff
and I think they're only like ten actual
legendaries in the game I'm gonna calm
legendre's to shared too much yeah
they're yeah alright one more way to go
no we're already halfway through the
dress rank can i yes I can oh we don't
have any of my stuff I keep forgetting
just bump it up while I can do those
repairs go into your single player I
think if you repair a thing it stays
repaired I'm going to do this because
that's super easy
so basically once you beat it you get
you know new survivors or potential
rescue you I guess boss is to fight in a
way creature bosses I think kudus I've
mentioned there's more thinking the Osho
after the Hard difficulty maybe lately
more difficulties I'm gonna do it oh
there's gonna be more elemental types of
wanders and if you're not the proper
weapons you'll be screwed
I did see kind of like a teaser that
like at one point I had to go and rescue
someone and there was like a a group of
Wanderers that were surrounded by like a
red colored thing or something but they
didn't make me go in to fight them it
was just kind of like I thought yeah
right I love you all game thought but at
Konami no dude that's fair fair yeah so
he thinks that the elemental stuff will
be like later like past hard I guess or
whatever past hard well maybe that's
like the next she are like stack up for
your loadout yeah like it's like destiny
we're like you have certain modifiers
and like you know you just have to make
sure you cover your bases in terms of
I'm just gonna calm down your side maybe
you're frosty sword will have like a
like make its way
you guys collectively share pawns are
you there goes an armored the shotguns
very good yes it is quite good I liked
it a lot I had to go through them but
man yo is horrid there's two secret
bosses for an achievement who that's
cool our trophy is what JC's bus this is
so it is kind of cool they do have like
the like all this other stuff that kind
of happens at the end I'm gonna pick up
that guy's mine it makes me wonder if
there's gonna be like what if they put
some sort of weird teaser at the end of
doing all the stuff I've been reading a
lot of it never be game over subreddit
because I'm awful so I'm like real real
into that right now
pick it up
oh these things are awful I have not
seen that guy before I try he was like
nah this is not a good place to do it
this isn't my scene not into it hi there
he's back he's dead
no problem he likes to kick people and
knock them over
it's a real mess don't you that's me
feel like they're on the yeah they are
they're definitely on it do you lose
points for that so what it does is it
stops the boosts which means you won't
get to s-rank it's a constant fight to
keep stuff away from or are you do you
have to get to the very edge to get S
rank or you technically already have it
right so you hit the end of it and then
that's when you get it yeah so you guys
are a little off right now yeah I think
we've got more than enough time to
actually hit it though I think I think
we're good yeah hope you can't spot so
you have to separate through this game
no I mean like I was interested I wanted
to know what this would it look like
after the single-player cuz yeah you
know it's
was there something worth it while you
know was there not it's being curious
about it it's it's an unknown thing it's
been playing and I don't have to wait
it's true you're you're kind of just
hanging out come along for that yeah I
get all the benefits without actually
having to put in the investment so you
know how do you hear you oh there goes
your arm oh you hit s Oh bomber what
get out stop this bend the knee
there we go so the good thing about this
is we've already hit s-rank so
everything else is just extra even if it
gets blown up oh really
yeah interesting so you can't lose
points unless we die and then the whole
thing is a wash okay well sure but we've
only got 30 seconds
have you done any of the hard stuff I
did one last night and it was not a joke
and as before the hotfix have been
gotcha so you're thinking maybe it's
more doable now yeah we jumping we try
that out
definitely not sponsored killa Chris I
wish I could tell you that it was but
it's not we'd have to disclose if we
were that Bentley we gave it a 5 out of
10 if you guys are curious at all
there's more guys or while we didn't two
more did yeah I feel like five five I
might have given it like a 6 myself okay
fine if I did but yes but even then it's
like yeah that's fine yeah I could see
it
try to remember how they changed all the
controls oh there we go
it's trying to get it really cool oh
it's worse after the patch for hard
ranked according to Cole
really that's not what I need to hear
worse you say well I wonder if anyone
has someone someone bumped me don't
leave me hanging
don't leave can't believe this
alright again some materials yeah I'm
just waiting for the Konami to release a
Metal Gear game where cardboard boxes
are the actual tea boxes in it should
take something that I love so much and
just kind of run it into the ground why
do you give them these why do I put it
out into the universe I'm more prepared
for it when it happens inevitably
someone's like taking notes like yeah
yes your fans they love cardboard boxes
ah take advantage of the fact that
that's the last place I did not pull my
weight at all you get you weren't
killing anything you're picking up stuff
slow you know why you didn't use your
shotgun enough it's true I didn't have
enough ammo oh I'm still in the point
right I'm trying to recover from rushing
to the last mission apparently it's much
harder to get s-rank now and hard you
have to do it perfectly no damage no
yeah tasty bus eh yeah you can backstop
the Bombers no explosions went in that
case it worked out because we got Splash
Damage on the guys neck it probably
wasn't a good thing so close to the
actual machine all right what's the plan
now Ben I'm gonna craft some ammo so I
can actually maybe do some more things
they have so again are you changing
games
we're just streaming for about an hour
yeah it's just wanted to see what that
uh
some of the end game looks like see
check out those you know subclasses
those subclasses are those only for your
single-player or is it a cure this - ok
cool that's cool yeah i'ma craft this
why not
[Music]
so actually think I have ammo for that
which is a good thing
and that way I'll have have a gun that
can actually do stuff at least there we
go
and think if I just go to fill myself up
I'll be good with arrows there we go hmm
all right all right do we want to try a
hard one I don't know it's up to you
well I don't give it a go see how it
goes whatever
Yolo I'm in I've never done a hard yet
huh look at orange here yeah that's
that's real real dangerous that's
there's a chance I would assume right I
think so okay do you have to pay for the
end content no you just got beat the
comb it's just finished you have to
whether the whole thing to weather that
storm so that's that's the deal I'm
gonna get in here and these people are
gonna be like 60s and 70s in clothing
and they're gonna be like dude get out
of here what are you doing you think so
no okay I'm curious I want to know like
well that first time we played or maybe
I was just when I stopped by and look at
your scream it's like a 10 level
difference so probably I could see a 50
like what levels kudos he seems to be
playing a lot there's definitely I feel
like there's a divide because there are
people who are actually playing this
really hardcore and then there are
people who are like playing it like me
were like I want to get through it and
kind of like see the stuff at least to
like say that I did it
blah blah someone wants to know outside
of the money greed stuff what are the
other complaints you've gotten so far
about the game or had so far from the
game I'm just not big into survival
games which I guess is my biggest thing
so it's it's just a thing that I'm not
200 percent down with but it's
functional and it works it just there's
nothing extraordinary about it and it is
definitely them just using the name and
then also I think one of the things you
mentioned to me or like during the last
room was that like somehow they made the
Fox engine potentially like run worse or
something because like framerate drops
and things like that weird hitches
sometimes it doesn't run like as well as
five did
it definitely has a smaller map I think
I see kudos is 51 but he also said we we
probably fine okay but doesn't look like
anyone's playing just gotta find someone
to play with
I thought that hitch was gonna be right
I thought that little stutter was gonna
be like yeah here we go
how's the connection happening yeah do
you think the the next move for them is
to make like a battle royale game can't
you do it from this somehow yeah like
like a milky royale yeah I saw someone
mentioned that earlier like why didn't
they just do that instead of this who
are those guys friends they both have
soul same soul in the name didn't change
out their their name plate at all these
guys are hardcore you think they're
gonna back out I want to see this 40
like yeah why you in here bro I was one
cured crystal coming out of half of a
head there's a lot of weird plot stuff
that doesn't entirely make a lot of
sense but there there's a lot of like
just dumb kind of like I'd say it's like
a metal gear level of dumb because metal
gear is its own level of dumb but like
somehow they managed to take like the
metal gear level of dumb and then just
make it even bigger it's the stories
just just bad so oh there you go boom
she's probably just less people queuing
up for hardened because I would assume
as kudos had mentioned it got harder
somehow to get ass at least yeah and I
feel like when you did like normal like
it was pretty instant it was like 37
also final floor around that level
because it's a good way to get your gear
up because there's a chance to get an
epic okay but you know you're still here
Chris player because you enjoy me and
Ben's company what is what I'd like to
think yeah I mean I hope one could only
hope Wow he's got all purples that guy's
got all purples greens there's a lot of
turret he doesn't have any orange yeah
person doesn't have any items they're
all ghost items
SiC best items goes to items I recommend
this for anyone who hasn't played a
middle of your game I've never played an
entry in the franchise and I think it
would be a survival type of game it
looks if it looked interesting to you'll
probably have a good time especially if
you like survival games there's a lot of
really cool systems for that in it and
the fact that you don't have that metal
gear time might might make it more more
I guess less painful yeah yeah I don't
know yeah you know what I mean it's only
40 bucks
it'll probably drop in price even more
with how not well it's selling oh yeah I
keep it on your radar you'll probably
find something to enjoy if you like
survival games all right time to go
search for some stuff let's see how we
do we're doing a hard hard mode I might
just have to hide some pro op sesh
feeling it you think so yeah yeah what
level could that thing possibly be I
don't want to look this ass didn't turn
around and look at me I'm gonna
Sassanian that's not gonna die dad
it's only 40 I think it actually like
averages out people's levels for the
enemies well they should have been more
in the mid forties thing because you got
a 52 I think maybe it's not like an
average more like a mean how many hours
have you played roughly maybe like okay
so for someone to be like 52 they
probably played even more than theirs
I'm just trying to gauge how long it
takes to level and stuff I think that
when you when you get far enough in
where your subclass level boosts your
regular level okay so it's like kind of
like it's like destiny light level stuff
so there's something going on with it
I'm not exactly sure what but it's
definitely a thing ooh secure that woo
now you saw and heard nothing
gotcha
someone's already getting that box
that's good I grab this stuff Allen
Paris can saw cher bono Gary survived it
depends man it really depends if you're
not in a hurry has been said you're
probably going discount soon if you're
interested maybe just wait it out a
little bit but if for some reason you
you know you find that it's it looks
like something right up your alley and
you're not really playing anything else
maybe yeah or get monster on our world
because I came was really good I got to
play
I got to play that today and it was it
was a really good feeling
wait what game I'm monster honor oh yeah
okay it's like oh man I remember one Mon
home I don't know man I finally got a
polished gem which thank God
yeah I know no man I think I got a I got
a weapon swap or something cuz I'm
starting to get kind of like yeah yeah
so try out that bow that you got it's a
pretty good bow I actually wanted like a
hunt with it just to kind of mess around
with it it's good what up what you got
going on in here Anne I think what else
is coming out in March I know C of
Thieves
so use and then Far Cry 5 I'm curious
about far cry yeah I'm sure all given an
event we're gonna have some preview
stuff end of this week or something that
I forget 1 dia bar goes but that's on
the horizon that's all I can really say
though yeah
Christopher Granger says your subclasses
level stack onto your over levels
overall levels you cap at 40 and then
get more from the subclass levels there
you go
okay so technically you're 37 then cuz
you have three subclass levels is that
right yeah thanks oh okay makes she call
me 85 unfortunately I don't think I can
read all that japenese I definitely
can't read that kanji thing he did ask a
question because I saw desu ka' at the
end of it everyone should be playing
Worcester Aaron or 69 hours in and
haven't spent the dime extra yeah I'm
like 150 hours in tomorrow 300
yowzers it's it's a very good video game
the only time you would have had to
expend any money like outside of just
the game if you want something though
was the Street Fighter 5 stuff so I
didn't have the Street Fighter 5 arcade
save data which I guess you could get
from anyone but still like I didn't have
any of that so I would have had to like
potentially purchase it yeah but that's
about it but that's just to get a Ryu
costume so it's kind of like an yeah I
guess the emotes if you really want to
do them there's a costume for the
handler which I definitely bought
because it changes her into the guild
model from before yeah totally a cool
game that doesn't have any like a bad
microtransactions or doesn't mistreat
your time be asking is this game good
well depends on you boy ruined that for
everyone I'm just gonna coast tide
you're gonna s rank this come on
have faith I mean that instant I
definitely ruined the hoe yeah it's fine
that guy was trying to sneak up on it
and I was like oh hey I'm gonna start
stomping around over here and cause it
to literally black noise and stuff oh
wait there's a support digger too huh
what is this is that like an additional
maybe like a sidequest ee thing maybe
come over here and hang out with these
people I know it's up where's that gun
here oh he probably made that right
definitely a lot of these people have to
seem sub-classes me so they probably
have the thing where it refills amo
while you use it to mmm this is this is
pretty alright
oh there they're all coming from out
there there's so many dudes dropping in
hi
they're gonna grenade them see these
guys are they're using like the the
stuff your soul oh is that like how do i
lure them together yeah let's see oh
yeah this is good
put us in your backpack these are good
please carry me nobody minds a nice
little carry all right they're like
leveling the stuff up he's being real
good with his ammunition sure I'm gonna
I'll help I'll light them on fire
yeah look at that Oh dance around bolli
tickling them okay that's just the next
phase whoo there that's doing some work
Ben yeah
fire fire is always a good time Oh is he
you're gonna tear it now or the it's Oh
this is going fine here we were here we
were doubting uh Here I am getting
writing a line of fire
this guy's like feathering I like it
he's conserving ammunition very real oh
wow what is oh he's got the hammer throw
dude he was like here your buddies are
gonna get rekt to feel bad that I'm like
I literally don't have like my loadout
like stacked up or anything I'm just
kind of like oh I thought you did some
upgrades no god I got like ammo for some
of my stuff but like I don't have all my
parts don't throw them to me draw them
back to you Wow oh that's a that's a
skull enemy look at an elite or
something going on shot that guy out of
the air oh my gosh I know
right in the neck the bomber coming and
armored coming
we're currently added egrave could be
worse feel like it's it's happening you
know there's stuff going whoa we popped
his helmet off the armor don't tell me
it's my show now no yes
Ben also conserving ammo he's doing some
counter some close quarters combat oh
look at that
this guy is not afraid no he's just a me
I gotta save ammunition for the next
phase is probably special abilities are
so good oh she just just keep pushing
him down when asked you didn't get the
BP for the improved molotovs I'm not
sure I don't think I found the blue yeah
thank you
which I guess that's the other kind of
thing that I'm kind of not down with his
like if I don't find the blueprint for a
thing really sorry my really was that I
didn't know that blood-borne it was part
of PS Plus Marshall I know yeah that is
hot that's that's right that's a good
excuse to streaming oh there you go
I don't care I love that game a lot
there's uh there was like a thing in the
office where I don't think I would win
because I don't think I'm not
necessarily good at speedruns but John
Luke was pretty confident about like
speedrunning blood-borne just gonna say
you guys should be your race I don't
know if we can do that in time I don't
even know what the speedrun looks like I
just enjoy playing the game you've got
like a week to kind of practice and
prepare and you know it doesn't have to
be like a proper speedrun it just has to
be like a speedrunning that you guys
kind of know what you're doing
yikes first phase did it right rank that
bag I don't know if we made it to D but
you you both diggers are at 100% salt
salt is is impressed apparently like how
else would you have been that better
like what would you have what could you
have done to get more points I'm an
unknown territory right all right sick
this is dangerous
this is this is excited yeah okay oh I'm
going to get some more shopping shows
because this is a thing that I can drive
your time just let me there we go Dio
Brando saying does this feel like a full
game or does it seem like it should have
been part of a like mmm GS 5 DLC I feel
like it probably been good as a DLC
thing it feels kind of like undead
nightmare is the only way I can kind of
think about it for Red Dead apparently
the yeah barely D apparently the other
waves get longer so what what what is a
good score on hard to normally aim for
then if in a perfect world I guess maybe
maybe a see the other waves get longer
yeah that's that's gonna be that's gonna
be the thing so why did I not get rid of
this why do I have this in my inventory
still because it's fun it's just a
slingshot it's when you have stones for
your slingshot I think except those are
more useful though I guess I think you
have to craft specific ammo just for it
which is medical supplies it's okay
because I we're I don't have to play it
after this like away just be done I know
I won't they'll definitely come back so
yeah you will you will they always come
back then come back I'll check in my
tomato farm see what's going on
I'm gonna be like boss it's been six
months since we've seen you
up until the patch s but now a 2's is
what you should be aiming for after the
first we would wait are we talking first
wave kudos are we talking about the
whole thing I'm hoping you mean the
whole thing I don't think you
do you have the first wave I don't know
about that yeah I don't know about that
I'm gonna guess he means the whole thing
which is fine oh look at this
this is a different place than I thought
it was oh no this is just a support one
I mean I'm down to just press go if
these people are apparently the
slingshot uses an animal that only takes
a turn oh that's cool I guess I don't
think it does damage though I think it's
more of like a distraction thing like
hey come over here
like hey look over this way which is
weird because that's also what these
things do kudos ed the whole thing hey
des so we'll see alright we're on pace
for that now he says that's the entire
match so we'll see let's check this
really quick there it is that's what we
need to build towards Oh tactical heavy
weapon yeah what do you think that is I
know what that is you know what it is
no are we gonna get there though we'll
find out then if we don't get there do
gonna lose my world my shizzle we're
working on it this is that's our that's
our goal we cannot to look to get I must
be at a meeting right now but I'm
willing to forgo part of that meeting so
that we can see these things don't worry
about it's three o'clock don't worry
about it oh no why I mean it's gonna
take at least ten minutes that's fine
we're gonna finish it
I don't care well I will care if we
don't get what I want out of this it all
counts on these people carrying me okay
well I'm gonna do my best but these
these guys are like pros look at him
right now look at that he's slow walking
not a can see where he's making it this
is the intro to his his Metal Gear
survived PvP videos he's not even
worried about wasting ammo right now
he's got bigger things to deal with the
tactical heavy weapon is a last resort
do it for the change oh no we are doing
it I know doing it for the strong I
don't care I'm sorry why what happened
what did they lose out of that move on
lose anything oh so what's the what why
is that a bad thing
I don't maybe it'll be like oh why did
you spend all of our stuff and we could
have used it on a cool thing in that
outward I don't care selfish motive
here's the cool thing
mmm-hmm should probably be using my
heavy shots what I have more these so
I'm just gonna spam them till I run out
oh your poor man's arrows the poor man
arrows
day one starter and well I'm not even
gonna pick them up after I wow this guy
living at large
I'm people are thanking me some I'm
alright with that I guess maybe maybe
their last experience was so much worse
that this is already better that's what
I like to think I was like oh man
someone's actually he's contributing
supporting me even though we know that
they're garbage level 40 yikes everybody
get on the floor some good leg armor
that you got there my dude that's
supposed to shatter after a little bit
what am i doing now with your day one
arrows here oh my god you know 15 arrows
later maybe look there you go you nailed
it
mr. president you want to stab him there
we go yeah I won't take that from them
that was great communication without
communication you know we communicated
with our eyes we looked longingly into
each other and we saw was going on I
don't need to be here this is a bad
place to be
Callum filer he spent about what 40 or
50 hours roughly about 40 to 50 hours
and they asked the game full of things
to do it is I've actually probably could
have spent more time like so for the
last three missions I kind of started it
yeah you kind of just like rush through
it right oh hi I could have spent time
actually like getting my stuff set up
proper defenses everything else but some
kind of kind of struggling now because
of it oh that's not good I got a sniper
rifle
about try really can't wait though this
can't be good
you know I'm very excited I just hope
that they don't spend it on something
before that too
I want to believe that everyone is on
board with the metal gear train we're
all communicating with around yeah yeah
they know making it work they believe in
the heart of the metal gear show me old
Diamond Head yeah there you go it's like
a pimple we got it oh there's a guy on
the bigger I think
get out no not today
Oh what oh he's just clawing at your
feet okay yeah oh did it get hit
yesterday they're already moving on this
soul world persons oh you know I don't
play with them all the time both souls
clan soul who's actually out already
five out of ten tomorrow same video
review hopefully out by the end of the
day maybe maybe a little sooner than I
think I know is going through some key
ways
yeah I think it's getting q8o blow those
guys out yeah I think that was what that
plan up to I felt that everyone's so
supportive in this game
that's good good to know the community
is not toxic yeah I mean you give
everyone enough cool emotes I feel like
you're pretty well off oh yet the paper
equipment slots you is that true I don't
know that's what a de vida SE says
because he says you pay for safe slots
which we know about then he says you pay
for equipment slots which I didn't know
about and then he says you pay to deploy
extra scavenge units which we didn't
know what's you know about that one it's
everything follow that one's soul guys
almost dying he's that pixel like oh
yeah
turret time that's that's the one right
there alright wave clue way wait to even
cleared Oh secure some resources side
mission going gun turret what we need is
you know what we need we need we need a
metal gear a weapon to surpass metal
gear yeah I'm not gonna build I'm gonna
let them choose what we do you're just
gonna move all the time yeah go along
with the ride that's that's definitely
lay my head over this way and try to do
this side mission this might be the one
for the turret cuz if I get a turret I
can just post up and at least like
provide that support yeah yeah yeah as I
say I've only crafted equipment slots I
don't know if they like offer you later
on the choice to buy some diamonds I
haven't heard about that one so who
knows mm-hmm
okay detonator you've gotta have a box
Christopher Granger says the
singleplayer end game is all about main
base defense which drops hand manuals
for your teams at the base to increase
their effectiveness and more farm
/resource generators mr. president that
boy didn't see me yeah he's only it's a
line you see that laser just don't cross
the laser yeah oh I think he means
loadouts okay there you go
Oh like saved we gotta pay extra for
more loadout slots I don't know if I
need to pay for that I know but that's
just what he meant are they okay gotcha
all right how far are we away from our
boy week and when do we need to
tactically call it in I'm gonna call it
as soon as the options available by
tactical I mean real cool of course of
course not when like things are getting
bad but you know yeah you know I think
you're gonna get an A at least it looks
like from here I'll assuming you guys
survive yeah they'll be pretty good see
I craft anything kind of I make myself
some stuff if I can make more shotgun
shells that'd be a plus not very many
but some is better than none Ben it's
very true feeling good about this I
think I think well I didn't did you
check the thing I can't check it till it
starts going again cuz if I click on it
I think it well you should go to where
he's at cuz he says this way over over
in the back
I'll support digger Oh a little sleeve
where's this there is we should have
this stuff inside here give me nothing
never mind
you've already grabbed it right three
alright so we need to start up just got
to go please please stream please we can
do this we just I just wants to seize it
although I guess in some way you could
have well assuming it's what we think it
is we've technically seen it already but
I could probably run off and do some of
these side missions because I'm I'm
probably better off in a smaller thing
than helping them was that going to help
you get to 200 it is others I'm actually
gonna pick up some virus energy from
doing this one which is probably why
they're already running to it yeah
number four Marco oh no did you get hit
no they got away you did get the stuff
we needed to nice this guy's on point
praise for marco projects
see
hello watch out for that there's a yeah
you'll be fine I think I think you're
pretty far from them the ball myself
extra cold keeping it clean stay frosty
don't get up
what oh we got a little decoys oh boy
big bosses in the game we found him yeah
oh yeah yeah just like I remember him
this guy's like what are you doing why
are you selling old Walker gear resupply
no that's not what we want that's that's
spending the points they spent the point
they did yeah no I thought it was a
little side quest thing that he did it's
a side quest thing oh and they're also
on watch out for lay arm where I think
they're on it right now not anymore
oh yeah so we already executed I don't
know if it actually does actually spend
it it seemed like you did cuz you're
only at 70,000 of the Nova 160 over
there no can't believe this you're not
done with this game then I don't even
have a I don't even no one's even using
the Walker gears I want to grab one so I
can at least kill some stuff I'm so sad
it wasn't worth it wasn't worth being
late anymore we shouldn't we should just
told everyone I've been like hey oh how
do we tell them Walker it's no longer
manually type in the chat no s rank the
blue stuff yeah we know we're we weren't
even we weren't getting s rank what I
wanted was to call in the big tactical
or the giant toughness aka the metal gia
but then someone called these stupid
walkers and instead I don't want to hit
you maybe they viewed it as they weren't
gonna beat it without doing this I don't
think so I feel like we have it under
control
I'm the one who's not doing a lot feel
like you're gonna get to a though yeah
that'll be pretty good you know we're
gonna get some good gear out of this and
I feel like that's that's what's good
we've all learned and grown as a group
and you know end of the day that's what
matters know what matters to me is that
I wanted to see a metal gear I want to
see that I was like oh this is it we're
actually gonna do it feels bad man and
all of all of our hopes and dreams
dashed and is in an instant it was it is
not a slow day today I've actually been
real busy and you I don't you know what
and I felt real good I felt like you
know we were getting to a penultimate
moment and then someone done and gone
ruined it
cuz now we're a hundred K short of a
tactical heavy weapon so got four
minutes we would have got there
we've just gained like 30 40 thousand we
have four minutes again a hundred
thousand knives somehow I'm willing to
bet you a soda that we're not getting
there I don't I don't think we are
either positive
yeah feather Wow bouncing off of him
ya can't bounce off of him I mean as fun
as this is we've seen this right yeah
this is old never hears Walker's old
news mostly metal your ray come down
from the sky and just destroy ah I you
know what I probably can't quit playing
this game until I see that I think so
and then somebody said before that
there's actually more than one or
something unless it was that other one
that you were telling me about in which
gave them I'm sure we'll find out we'll
find out someday eventually someday was
supposed to be today bad day was
supposed to be today but then we had
these randoms that decided to buy these
Walker gears later monster the otic died
otic thanks for stopping by thanks you
know it's good seeing you
did you think maybe maybe in one there's
like one minute left
maybe dude we're at a this is pretty
good pretty close to an s come on 150 at
least at least make it a tease we have
124 you can see it at the bottom there
oh yeah I still really good which I'm
gonna have to use at a pool because I'm
out of ammo now hey yeah
it's gonna be the dumbest Oh I'd almost
killed the armor in one shot though yeah
I think it usually does but you're low
level yeah they stopped the game I don't
think so
right I think it's the tracker came in
in touch date cuz they literally like
their whole purpose is just jumping in
on stuff oh it's on fire
yeah oh man
it's your show now ooh marksmanship
click-click well back to horizon zero
dawn here we are
oh you just come in here and swoop on it
like that that's good
whoa from downtown's good it's a good
shot
dude we were so close to an s is it
possible to still get in this probably
not I think what you for off but it's
more than I thought it moved up more
than I thought that's for sure
but this is this is a better turnout for
this than I thought we'd have yeah you
doubted us I really did but we do have
some good players that seem to know what
they're doing not that you don't but you
know seems like they played the map okay
and I'm not afraid to admit Oh quickly
check maybe I doubt it there's no way
they're probably like a 150 gosh darn it
we would have easily had oh my gosh I'm
so sad right now then same no I'm I
could have walked into the meeting and
been like you know what I saw a Metal
Gear today I saw a Medicare today um you
know what I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
playing and I'm gonna find it I'm gonna
record it okay I'm gonna send it to you
on Twitter specifically okay so that you
can see it all right that's fair I can
do it I'm gonna do it just for you okay
I appreciate that all right let's see
what the rewards are and then we're
playing in college stream appreciate
everyone that for tuning in either you
know good or bad I realize this is one
of those games that's gonna get some of
that uh you negativity and you know hey
check out the review from temor give it
a 5 out of 10
any last thoughts other than the lack of
Metal Gear then from your end now that
you've gotten this far
I miss Metal Gear oh you only get okay I
was gonna say you only get two boxes
it's the only a3 with an A oh wow good
thing you gave him the little handshake
there secret handshake before you guys
it was too good for him handling or he
was sad that he was getting left hanging
it's like I don't want to go out this
way he was leaving unfortunately that
guy really did nothing what that guy did
absolutely nothing I think he might have
actually done nothing he no but what's
that the guy that won and did that side
quest thing that's the thousand points
right there Wow all right yeah check it
check it out check out the review video
reviews gonna come in soon yeah endgame
seems to be like you know trying to
unlock your subclasses leveling the
subclasses out going and gathering more
resources and things like that you know
get the Queen suss out with quite steam
is playing sounds good that's great
all right thanks Ben so thank you thanks
everyone for tuning in we'll be back
tomorrow 11:00 a.m. as per huge we
appreciate you guys all hanging out and
have yourselves a nice quiet evening
take it easy